Um, long legs, anyone? Hello.
Okay. It's the new jumpsuit from Allara.
I love the flattering neckline.
It's really nice and fitted up top.
Then are you like,
how do you even get that thing on?
There's a zipper.
There's a hidden.
You can't even see it.
It's got a little hook right here so it does not come undone.
This thing is just amazing.
This perfection because of the high waistline and the wide pant length.
And it make your body look beautiful at every single size.
And they do have plus sizes.
Go and find your size.
Got this in medium.
I'm about 5 9 and 165 pounds.
A lot of clothes are just made to fit beautifully.
There is a huge discount for first time users of the TikTok Shop.
And you do not have to worry about sizing
because they have free shipping and free returns.
The link is right here.